Es besteht Gefahr für Mensch und Tier.
Das Usutu-Virus hat Deutschland im Griff und
sorgt für den qualvollen Tod von Amseln und
anderen Singvögeln.
Und zwar massenweise!
Und ja, die Gefahr ist da: Denn die Stechmücken,
die die Vögel mit dem Virus infizieren, können
es auch auf andere Tiere und Menschen übertragen.
Jetzt wird auch die Bevölkerung um Mithilfe
gebeten.
Der Aufruf jetzt bei Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Täglich Wissenschaft gibt es bei uns - Abonniert
den Kanal.
Nur dann verpasst ihr kein Video.
Let’s Go!
Herzlich willkommen!
Vielen Dank für diesen spannenden Themenvorschlag,
den ihr mir über Whats App geschickt habt!
Zu meiner persönlichen Nummer für Themenvorschläge
und die tägliche Nachricht an auch persönlich
von mir mit dem Videolink vorab findet ihr
in der Videobeschreibung!
Benannt ist das tropische Usutu-Virus nach
einem Fluss im südlichen Afrika, wo es ursprünglich
herkommt.
Stechmücken übertragen das Virus auf Vögel
- und vor allem Amseln und andere Singvögel
sind anfällig.
Deswegen wird die Erkrankung auch als “Amselsterben”
bezeichnet.
Ihre Leidensgeschichte ist schlimm: Die Tiere
taumeln, verdrehen den Kopf, werden apathisch,
können nicht mehr flüchten und sterben innerhalb
einiger Tage.
Das Fatale: Diese Usutu-Infektionen können
weder behandelt noch verhindert werden.
Laut Nabu gehen die Amselzahlen in den Ausbruchs-Gebieten
deutlich zurück.
Und auch andere Tiere wie Fledermäuse oder
Pferde können sich infizieren.
Doch dazu gibt es laut dem Bernhard-Nocht-Institut
für Tropenmedizin in Hamburg kaum belastbare
Daten.
Die Übertragung auf den Menschen geschieht
ebenso über Stechmücken - passiert aber
eher zufällig.
Die Folge: das sogenannte Usutu-Virus mit
Fieber, Hautausschlägen, Kopfschmerzen als
Symptomen.
Selten kann es auch zu Gehirnentzündungen
kommen.
Bislang wurden zwei Infektionen entdeckt,
die bei den Betroffenen aber keine Erkrankung
ausgelöst hatten.
Doch fest steht: Die Personen hatten sich
in Deutschland angesteckt, denn sie hatten
vorher keine Reisen unternommen.
Dazu das Bernhard-Nocht-Institut für Tropenmedizin:
“Eine Infektion mit dem Usutu-Virus scheint
also in Deutschland möglich, ist aber noch
kein Grund zu Sorge und wird von Blutspendezentren
gemeinsam mit wissenschaftlichen Institutionen
weiter beobachtet.”
Nach Angaben des Naturschutzbundes Deutschland
(Nabu) gab es Ende August (28.8.18) jedenfalls
bereits 5.000 Meldungen mit mehr als 10.000
kranken oder verendeten Tieren.
Darunter Amseln, aber auch Meisen, Haussperlinge
und andere Arten.
Und diese Zahlen toppen alles.
Denn seit 2011, als diese Art des Vogesterbens,
das erste Mal in Deutschland auftrat, waren
im Spätsommer immer wieder mal einige Regionen
des Landes betroffen.
Vor allem aber wärmere Gebiete wie entlang
des Rheintals und am Untermain.
Seit 2016 hat sich das Virus dann über Nordrhein-Westfalen
nach Norden und Richtung Bayern ausgebreitet.
In diesem Jahr sind vor allem Nürnberg, Bremen
und Hamburg betroffen.
Zwar zum ersten Mal - dafür aber ganz besonders
schlimm.
Dazu der Nabu auf seiner Website: “Ornithologen
und Tropenmediziner konnten seit 2011 feststellen,
dass immer dann besonders viele Vögel verenden,
wenn das Virus erstmals in einer Region auftritt,
wie derzeit um Nürnberg, Bremen und Hamburg.
In den Folgejahren sinken die Todeszahlen
dann auf ein niedrigeres Niveau.”
Die Experten gehen davon aus, dass vor allem
der warme Sommer die Ausbreitung des Virus
vorangetrieben hat.
Und die Fachleute sind machtlos, denn die
Todesfälle können nicht verhindert werden.
Bislang ist laut Nabu noch nicht das Schlimmste
zu befürchten: eine allgemeine Gefährdung
der Amseln bzw. deren Aussterben.
Denn nach den Ausbrüchen gingen die Zahlen
langsam wieder nach oben und haben sich teilweise
stabilisiert - allerdings auf einem niedrigeren
Niveau als vorher.
Doch lokal kann es tatsächlich sein, dass
die Vögel wegen des Virus vorübergehend
fast komplett verschwinden.
Das einzige, was zu tun bleibt: Die Auswirkungen
der Vogelkrankheit genau zu dokumentieren.
Dazu hat der Nabu jetzt auch die Bevölkerung
aufgerufen.
Auf der Website sollen kranke oder tote Amseln
gemeldet werden.
Wichtig dabei: Genaue Angaben zu Fundort,
-datum und -umständen.
So kann das Ausbruchsgeschehen genau verfolgt
werden und neue Ausbruchsregionen identifiziert
werden.
Um das Virus besser zu verstehen, können
auch Fotos betroffener Vögel helfen.
Zudem sollen verendete Vögel zur Untersuchung
ins Labor geschickt werden.
Beispielsweise ins Bernhard-Nocht-Institut
in Hamburg.
Benutzt dabei auf jeden Fall Handschuhe oder
eine umgestülpte Plastiktüte und vergesst
das Händewaschen danach nicht.
Denn wir stehen alle in der Verantwortung:
NOCH gibt es in Deutschland etwa doppelt so
viele Vögel wie Menschen.
Doch nicht nur solche Infektionskrankheiten
wie das Usutu-Virus lassen ihre Zahlen immer
weiter sinken.
Auch menschengemachte Faktoren wie etwa der
Klimawandel, der Lebensraumverlust und das
große Insektensterben gefährden den Vogelbestand
enorm.
Und Viren können immer mutieren und dann
kann es auch für Menschen richtig gefährlich
werden.
Wir bleiben dran.
Wenn ihr kein Video zu solchen Themen verpassen
wollt, dann abonniert auch den englischen
Clixoom-Kanal.
Dafür einfach hier klicken.
Auch da gibt es die ein oder andere Videopremiere!
Hier geht es weiter mit: „Mystery of the
alien mummy revealed“ See you soon - stay
tuned!